another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the scp foundation dr  bright is not allowed to apply  scp-963 to any major political figures  again  so we've got some background here anyone  who has seen our video on  scp-4444 will know that a species of  aliens almost destroyed our planet in  the year 2000 after they possessed  presidential candidate al gore in order  to stop them dr bright needed to take  over the body of george w bush to run  against him while this was an emergency  where certain risks needed to be taken  our current geopolitical landscape is  already too wild and too fractious to  risk dr bright ever rising to any kind  of political power though if he did he'd  probably run on the major campaign  slogan ah come on guys you've had worse